[Musica]
400 miliardi di stelle sono così tante
le stelle in cielo non le possiamo
vedere tutte è però nella via lattea
dove c'è la maggiore concentrazione di
stelle ci sono anche delle enormi nuvole
di gas fatte di grafite la sostanza
delle matite di silicati come la sabbia
di ghiacci e queste enormi nuvole sono
un milione di volte più grandi della
terra e sono freddissime 250 gradi sotto
zero noi sappiamo che il gas quando è
caldo si espande e invece queste nuvole
sono fredde e la forza di gravità che
hanno è così grande da schiacciarle
sotto il loro stesso peso in più queste
nuvole ruotano quindi la forza
centrifuga le frena sull'equatore e
tendono a schiacciarsi ora quando noi
compiamo la gomma di una bicicletta e
comprimiamo l'aria col nostro braccio
riusciamo a riscaldare la pompa 40 gradi
pensate questi milioni milioni di
tonnellate di materia riescono ad
arrivare addirittura a superare i 10
milioni di gradi l'idrogeno quando
supera i 10 milioni di gradi
entra nel processo che si ama fusione
nucleare si trasforma e diventa elio e
lelio poi nella fusione nucleare diventa
carbonio azoto ossigeno e poi anche il
carbonio azoto ossigeno formano gli
altri elementi quindi tutti gli elementi
che noi abbiamo qui quelli di cui siamo
fatti noi di cui è fatto questo palco le
vostre sedie sono all'inizio forzati nel
core nella parte centrale di tutte
queste stelle le stelle più grandi di
nove volte il sole
alla fine della loro vita esplodono
nello spazio fanno una gigantesca
esplosione detta di supernova è tutta
questa ricchezza chimica viene sparsa
nello spazio come delle enormi
esplosioni nucleari a fungo il materiale
cioè i nuovi elementi chimici si
spargono nella galassia
e qui si formano molecole fino ad
arrivare molecole complesse come
probabilmente aminoacidi o altre
sostanze
quindi il
questo ciclo che semplicemente dettato
dalle leggi della fisica non ha nulla di
straordinario ci dice che qualunque sia
il meccanismo per cui è nata la vita
sulla terra
questi elementi c'erano già ovunque
nella galassia p come dall'altro lato
bene il materiale che è rimasto intorno
a disco come vi dicevo fatto di grafite
quella materia delle matite o di
silicati come la sabbia ricoperta di
ghiacci d'acqua dalle carboniche altre
sostanze tende ad aggregarsi e a formare
degli oggetti estremamente grandi che
sono chiamati planetesimi ma il disco
ruota e quindi questi planetesimi non
stanno fermi nello spazio ma collidono
collidono tra loro per miliardi di anni
nel giro di 200 mila anni i planetesimi
iniziano a fondersi tra loro ea formare
i pianeti ovvero i proto pianeti quelli
che saranno i nostri pianeti passano
questi centinaia di migliaia d'anni i
pianeti si raffreddano ed ecco che nasce
il sistema solare ancora oggi ci sono
migliaia decine di migliaia di frammenti
di oggetti che chiamiamo asteroidi e
comete che ruotano intorno ai vari
pianeti alcuni di questi si muovono
entrano persino dentro l'orbita
terrestre ogni tanto qualcuno collide
con la terra con altri pianeti ma nella
parte esterna al di là dell'orbita di
nettuno
c'è un'altra fascia di asteroidi e di
comete sono oggetti ancora più e grandi
sono plutone e altri di questi pianeti
nani ma ci sono anche le comete
ebbene gli oggetti che noi studiamo le
meteoriti e le comete che arrivano sulla
terra contengono già delle sostanze
chimiche come amminoacidi come lipidi
che sono i grassi di cui sono fatte le
varie di cellulari e anche delle dei
pezzi delle basi azotate che sono parti
del dna rna tutti questi oggetti hanno
colpito per un miliardo danni la terra e
quindi è pensabile che se i pianeti
inizialmente
sono estremamente caldi
se il vapor d'acqua dei vulcani ha
formato i nostri oceani in questi oceani
sterili di acqua bollita sono arrivate
poi con le meteoriti o con le comete
tutte queste sostanze prebiotiche cioè
che premettono alla nascita della vita
bene gli oceani in base alle prime rocce
sedimentarie i sono formate sulla terra
sono nate 3,9 miliardi di anni fa a
questa epoca si trovano già tracce
chimiche di vita quindi la vita dovrebbe
essere nata quasi contemporaneamente
ma non è finita circa 2 miliardi di anni
fa
le forme di vita terrestri hanno una
rivoluzione è un'altra pietra miliare
dopo la formazione della terra e la
nascita della fotosintesi la fotosintesi
trame laclos tramite la clorofilla
assorbe l'anidride carbonica
dall'atmosfera lascia l'azoto crea
l'ossigeno la fotosintesi cambia
completamente l'atmosfera terrestre
quindi se oggi guardiamo la terra ci
sembra un posto meraviglioso
straordinario unico con tanti animali
con tante piante è un posto fantastico
in realtà non è unico non è
straordinario non è così perché ci sono
delle forme di vita per esempio che si
sono adattate all'interno dei mari nei
fondali marini a 800 metri profondità
vicino a vulcano i sottomarini sono i
vermi a tubo per esempio che sono
autosufficienti vivono al buio e col
calore dei vulcani dove il ghiaccio
mescolato al metano ha formato dei
ghiacci nel fondali marini ma esistono
dei vermi del metano ci sono batteri nel
sottosuolo
alcuni addirittura nello spazio che sono
in grado di vivere nello spazio
noi umani rappresentiamo lo 0 0 1 per
cento
ma ci chiediamo a questo punto nel resto
della via lattea
ebbene dopo la prima scoperta nel 91 del
primo pianeta extrasolare ogni settimana
se ne scoprono di nuovi e
l'ultima volta che ho guardato
l'archivio il 5 ottobre
c'erano 4000 118 pianeti intorno a 3.060
tre stelle
quello che ci interessa è che alcuni di
questi pianeti sono grandi come la terra
ed alcuni di questi pianeti sono a una
distanza dalla stella per cui può
esserci acqua liquida in superficie e
bene e questi queste 22 terre che
potrebbero esserci sono oggetto di
studio che cosa possiamo studiare
possiamo studiare l'atmosfera di questi
pianeti alcuni quelli più grandi li
abbiamo fotografati li vediamo girare
intorno alla stella coprendo
opportunamente la stella ma ce ne sono
altri di cui si è scoperto syria sono
riusciti a vedere delle piogge il vapor
d'acqua in atmosfera ce ne sono altri su
cui potremmo scoprire l'ozono che un
prodotto biologico della clorofilla
della fotosintesi e potremmo scoprire
anche tracce della clorofilla perché la
clorofilla ascia un'evidente traccia
nella atmosfera e nel riflesso della
luce solare quando passa nell'atmosfera
del pianeta
questo può succedere domani tra un mese
tra un anno per esempio la stella
teegarden che più piccola del sole una
nana rossa e più fredda a due pianeti
che sono così vicini che possono avere
l'acqua liquida in superficie teegarden
b e c teegarden di potrebbe avere un
enorme oceano che cosa bisogna studiare
appena gli strumenti ce lo consentiranno
bisogna studiare la presenza di ossigeno
di ozono e di clorofilla e sull'altro
pianeta che invece è la luce è meno
intensa non si riesce a creare ossigeno
ma si può ancora trovare la presenza
della clorofilla quindi abbiamo visto
che la nascita di stelle pianeti e di
molecole simili a quelle della vita non
è un fenomeno straordinario ma è
universale
c'è ovunque nella nostra via lattea eni
miliardi di galassie come la via lattea
che ci sono nello spazio
avviene da 14 miliardi di anni dalla
nascita del cosmo e quindi non è un
fenomeno straordinario è dettato dalle
leggi fisiche
cosa potremmo scoprire ancora ci
dobbiamo rendere conto che siamo della
stessa sostanza di cui sono fatte le
stelle e quindi domani la ricerca
scientifica dei pianeti extrasolari ci
dirà che non siamo l'unica forma di vita
nella galassia
a quel punto la scoperta di clorofilla o
di ozono su un pianeta intorno a
un'altra stella sarà veramente veramente
una grande pietra miliare che farà fare
un balzo immenso alla nostra cultura
[Applauso]